welcome to this video playing Carol 0
from from Spain the room do we get a
main line for a change it looks like
young blame our tried and trusted sugar
in not the most aggressive line ever but
at least I have played like a gazillion
games with it this is this is actually
dangerous they tend to forget what's
what's right yeah queen of 394 this type
of game is not easy okay let's see let's
see I've got c4 yeah I've got this
counter play ideas with 97 95 yeah 95
there are sometimes ideas with 94 I
wonder if this is one of them one of the
positions where this is possible
94 here yeah probably i'm just making a
complete fool out of myself if i play
that hmm I lose I lose even very good
position so Maya might as well I might
as well gamble a bit the point is that
d3 d2 gets the piece back I Scott Bishop
f4 okay but I this is not I have a wait
wait wait wait wait just just just just
just a moment just a moment if I go to a
50 key 7 and takes on see to wear and
probably not good okay well then men
that's let's just exchange this is not
not so clear this position at least I
hope now it's not it's not so clear it
really isn't takes and I've got queen
before coming he has no easy way to
protect the beep on and the rookie
saying yeah maybe this paid off this
gambling move yeah yeah seems it seems
that i'm lucky in it it seems to work at
least said it it played out in a way
that it's working I really I don't see a
move him rookie 5 queen bee to is a
honey fork
how does he how does he continue here if
you place a move like Bishop e2 hoping
that I take I can't even take Beecham
yeah I just take him yeah I can take the
rook and white resigns yeah that was a
bit lucky I mean I just I just played
recklessly and it worked out they are
not sure if it is really good Humpty
form i-94 computer wants to play look Fe
ATM I did side it's interesting at least
to play that let's see you night f5
looks looks normal it goes here yeah
yeah this this is some compensation now
this is some compensation I mean a tan
in a blitz game it's it's it's clear
that it's it's probably enough not sure
if it's really sound here yeah it seems
that Queen takes is better yeah but the
computer is not completely laughing at
me and I kill haha what an idiotic dry
it seems to be a play or at least and
here I'm already already in good shape
as it seems shoot you six and what now
yeah I rook to e1 maybe rooked you wanna
this is maybe the best try I thought
queen before and then and then giving
giving up the bishop I mean you cannot
play something like that i mean this
this is too much all the points and do
I'd really has no play the special bond
be one is just dead so interesting
interesting home play it seemed to work
out a bit lucky i mean i justjust i know
this is a typical move in this type of
position but i just hope that it worked
and and and it did in fact at least for
one game thanks for watching